The coolest people to me
are probably our members
.
[Music]
It's a very cute tennis bag again. The
reason I picked this one
is not particularly big
anymore.  I
had dinner with
Hobby, and then I had a tennis appointment. Now, Hobie,
hey, you know how to play tennis. I
'm going to play tennis with my friends
.  I remember that the
special move was probably not my
special move, but J-Hope's career break
was another problem
.
Even if you haven't
played a few games, you're always very quick to understand
the
game
I've been playing games since I came in. I
'm just a person who enjoys it, but I'm not good at it, and I'm the
worst person.
He has no interest in games, and the
game itself is the
complete opposite
of V. He doesn't understand the game itself.
I came out with several of them and told them that I was going to play like this, but the next time
I went back
, it was really only up to the point where I played. So I gave up
.  It's like clothes. It's not
like a tattoo that you always have with you when you go out
.
The items I carry when I
borrow are fixed. Computer
keyboard, mouse, and pajamas.
For example, when I planned to make this pajama suit,
I
saw a blue color or something
related to an angel.
I had a dream, but I saw an angel, then I put an angel in it, and then
I went to work and said that the
river sold
it, and now I put in
a blue color
.
What if you cover it with the image of What was it like
? Should I just put one big
thing in my clothes or put a few small things in?
And in the meantime, what are you holding now
?
Shall I put it in?  The thing that covers the case now made with it
is my house card key,
so I don't want this to go out, so my favorite
app is, of course,
like a modern person, I use YouTube a lot. Now, in the
Korean market, webtoons
have also developed a lot.  There are
a lot of things to search for while doing it.
We need to know a lot of information, so we spend
about 360 days out of 365 days a year.
That's right, look ahead
. One of my favorite characters is a character named Pink
Bean. Now I wear this friend in my bag,
but when I go out, I
always carry this
bag with me
.  There are one or two more items except
here. Now here's
an orange mushroom, followed by
a keyring of a character called Yeti, which is a mixture of white and blue
.
Shoulder straps of the appropriate length that can be worn when it is annoying are very important. If I wear it as a
backpack, it is too cumbersome now,
and I value practicality more than design
.
What is this? What I
like most about this brand
is that it has something very simple. My fashion philosophy is
that if you spend money on clothes, I like it now that the
brand logo is hugely embedded
in
it.
If there's anything that inspires me,
it's annoying. I
don't really pay much attention to
fashion. The most important fashion, the face, is already complete, so
the
clothes are a little extra. To be honest, there are things in front of my eyes.
If
you look here, I have a hole in my clothes right now. I wore
them too often and brought them today
to have them repaired
. In the early days of my debut, I was a
person whose face stuck very well, but
I searched the Internet a
lot.  I might be weak, but
I
looked
for something good, and I had this friend as a representative. So I started taking this friend for a month or two, and
from then on, my
face didn't stick well again for a few years.
They don't stick together very well, so
my child friends are really indispensable friends while I'm living as a celebrity.
No, I don't really care
about my health, but I
care a lot about my face.
I don't know how many years ago,
but since then, I
wore them for about 300 days out of 365 days for about 2-3 years.  This is
a friend who has been with me more often than my wallet when I go out,
but those who have worn slippers know this, but when you wear
slippers, you get used
to
them.
I have to give it to you. So far,
I have introduced my stuff through Ten Essential
. Thank you to gq for inviting me
and please give lots of love to my new single Diestrotto.
Thank you.